ce combattant vient recouvrir la lettre
Z l'un des symboles de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par l'armée russe à la place
une vignette qui représente le corps des
volontaires russes ce groupe
farouchement opposé au Kremlin aurait
participé à l'incursion de Belgorod la
plus importante en territoire russe
depuis le début de la guerre en deux
jours plusieurs localités de Belgorod
ont été attaquées par la voix du
ministère russe de la Défense Moscou
affirme que l'offensive est terminée et
accuse directement Kiev lors de
l'opération antiterroriste grâce aux
frappes de l'aviation et de l'artillerie
et à l'action des unités de défense des
frontières du district militaire de
l'Ouest les formations nationalistes
ukrainiennes ont été bloquées et
écrasées le reste des nationalistes a
été reposé sur le territoire de
l'Ukraine où les frappes se sont
poursuivies jusqu'à leur élimination
totale
Igor konatchenkov ajoute que 78
Ukrainiens auraient été tués dans cette
contre-attaque une information
impossible à vérifier
le gouvernement de Kiev lui ni tout
implication dans cette incursion
l'opération a cependant été revendiquée
sur une chaîne télégram qui se présente
comme appartenant à un groupe de Russes
combattant du côté ukrainien
il est venu le temps de mettre fin à la
dictature du Kremlin merci beaucoup à
tous ceux qui nous soutiennent votre
soutien et ce qui nous rappelle chaque
jour notre objectif final sur la Place
Rouge
final soyez courageux et n'ayez pas peur
parce que nous revenons à la maison la
Russie sera libre
lundi la Russie avait décrété un régime
d'opérations antiterroriste dans cette
région de Belgorod frontalière de
l'Ukraine cette mesure levée depuis
donne plus de pouvoir aux autorités pour
mener des opérations armées ou encore
évacuer les populations